Hello Freak bitches.
If we go back to 10,000,
12,000 years ago,
clearly whatever happened then must've been profoundly traumatic to the
survivors.
Think about this.
If you were the survivor of an event that basically erased modern civilization
and you are living in a small isolated band of survivors with no way to
communicate with the rest of the world and no knowledge of whether there was
even other survivors anywhere on the earth.
It could profoundly affect your,
your,
your consciousness and and that could be so profound that it's the imprint of
those events can be so profound and it could be passed on
for generations and and be lodged in our subconscious.
This idea of human conflict necessary for human survival and the traumas that
had been visited upon our species by nature itself.
So I think that once we come to terms with the possibly origins of only until we
come to terms with the origin of human conflict,
are we going to be able to purge it once and for all?
And,
and realize that that the modern analog for that scenario was that coming out of
that catastrophe.
Abundant resources,
abundance,
habitat,
abundant space,
no conflict for territory or resources because the human population was limited.
What I suggest is that if people want to understand the viable future of the
human species,
go out on a crystal clear night and look at the sky.
There is the future.
There's our potential future because the scenario is that had been around since
the 1970 show that everything that we're extracting now from the earth,
the minerals,
the precious metals,
the hydrocarbons,
it's all out there in infinite abundance and it's basically just outside of our
doorstep.
And we are as close now to being able to harvest the resources of the cosmic
environment as we were from setting foot on the moon in 1960.
No,
nick and nate,
they get a painted to be these bad guys and you know,
that's part of the persona that they promote,
that that's all well and good.
But like they're very,
very respectable.
But you know,
when he,
um,
when Nick beat Frank Shamrock,
he was on the ground after the fight and nick reached down and picked him up and
said,
you know,
you're a legend.
You can't be on the floor,
stand up or whatever.
Yeah,
and this is,
but all the people see is they go for the stare down at the press conference.
Netflix,
I'm off and frank shamrock grabs his balls,
but they're both very respectful fighters in the,
you know,
I think they get,
they get a bad rap sometimes.
Well,
he definitely gets crazy before the fight and anxious and.
But that's to be expected and the shit talking.
Look sunsuit set it and the art of war,
you know,
a multi Musashi talked about it in the book of five rings did.
There's all sorts of things that go on in the fight and in contest there's
advantages to be had and there's a mental advantages that if you do not take
advantage of those mental advantages and your opponent does,
you're at a disadvantage.
And when nick immediately starts the fight and he's like,
he's got his hands out to Anderson,
like what Bitch,
what pitch?
And he's walking towards him.
Come on,
what the fuck you going to do?
what are you going to do?
And you see him talking,
like constantly talking and you just see Anderson,
like people get flustered when nick does that mean,
so it does it in sparring to tell the really high.
That's the first time I met Nicole was brought in for actually the,
uh,
for uh,
nate's fight with aunts Rooney.
And when I got to the gym,
uh,
nate had hurt his neck or something was going to the,
had to go to the chiropractor or something.
And they were like,
I'll just wait nickleby,
here you can spar with nick.
And I was like,
okay.
So like nick shows up and I'm a big fan of these guys,
you know,
like as I was Kinda like,
a little star struck and uh,
nick shows up and he's just
like
totally coast department.
I was like,
so what are we going?
Are we going to fight her tonight?
He's like unified right now,
you know,
and it.
But it was just like,
just like he walks into the cage,
you know,
kind of like just look at me up and down kind of thing.
And then,
you know,
we,
we started,
it was really hard and we had like a really good,
a really hard session and then after that he was like kickboxing,
Huh?
So if you want to hang out after,
you know,
we started hanging out after that,
but it was,
uh,
it was very much like a like is,
you know,
that's,
that's who he is,
you know,
just like I grew up in Libya,
Saudi Arabia,
Pakistan,
I didn't come to North America until I was 24.
I grew up in pretty much Muslim majority countries and some very conservative
ones all the time.
And you know,
I just,
whenever I hear people say that this has nothing to do with religion,
it just doesn't make any sense to me.
Is that like an American liberal convenient thing to say because it makes you
look super sensitive and very noam Chomsky ask?
Well yeah it does.
And then there's a um,
I don't know what goes into it.
I know that there's a lot of fear and you know,
people don't want to criticize this,
um,
you know,
we saw what happened with someone or I stayed all the way up to the Paris
attacks.
So there is a fear of that and there's also a fear of being seen as a bigot.
That was Brian.
I call it Islamophobia Phobia.
People are like,
great word and you know,
I'm a phobia phobia.
I love it.
It's something that a lot of people relate to immediately trigger it.
It is.
I hate that term.
Islamophobia.
And look,
what about Christian have phobia.
What's hilarious to me is that a lot of quote unquote progressive,
very left wing people will openly mock Christianity.
Yeah.
While defending Islam or by labeling people Islamophobic who conservative.
That,
I mean,
you gotta you gotta stay consistent.
If you're a true liberal,
and I know everybody's saying this,
well unfortunately,
not everybody's saying it.
I wish more people were saying it,
but you know,
if you are,
for instance,
opposed to killing gay people,
you should be opposed killing baby gay people.
Whether it's in the KKK manifesto or the Bible or the Koran,
or in the Republican Party,
you know,
or in Uganda,
it doesn't matter what it is,
if you're opposed to something you should be opposed to it across the board.
It doesn't suddenly become respectful that,
okay,
now,
well it's in the Bible,
so we got to respect that.
Know and it's respect for ideas is just such an overrated.
It's considered a virtue,
you know,
respecting people's ideas and beliefs and ideas are not people you know,
like that's,
and I was trying to,
that's the problem with the word Islamophobia is that it implies criticism of an
idea and there is genuine anti Muslim bigotry.
People do commit hate crimes against Muslims,
but Muslims are people.
They,
they're not.
I mean they're entitled to respect,
they have rights.
Islam itself is not a person.
It's just a,
it's a book.
It's an ideology.
It's an ideology,
a bunch of ideas in a book.
So it doesn't have rights and it's not entitled to respect.
I,
you know,
I didn't get to meet dangerfield and I Miss Carlin and I was like,
I just want to work with wrinkles at some point and then it came up that I could
work with them at in Montreal and I was supposed to go on vacation with my
family and I literally sent my wife and kids.
I'm like,
I'm going to meet it.
I'm going to be three days late to our family vacation.
I'm going to go work with wrinkles.
I had to is like,
this is.
Yeah.
As a comic,
that's an opportunity.
It's really hard to pass my whole objective.
Those two days was I just want to be shit on by him.
I was just lobbing stuff and I'm like done.
So,
uh,
but we're working together two nights,
so like,
you know,
after that we're going to know each other pretty well.
You think when you get back to la,
we're going to hang out.
Don't push it.
Then I'm like waiting for them with just totally that.
I like time.
Are you gonna?
Watch my act tonight.
I really appreciate it.
If you watch my act,
I had my little busy and then after the show I go back to his dressing room.
What the cool thing was.
You would love it.
He just,
it's like old school show business just walked into the building.
It's like,
you know,
even in Montreal it was kind of thing is everyone's doing shows all week when
hit when it was his time for the show,
guys in Tuxedos or walking around.
Security guys are hanging out old school guys with like,
you know,
gel in their hair and like show business is happening.
This is,
the halls are cleared and it's like,
this is just music,
classic music playing.
And it's like,
no,
we're doing a show.
Not Walking in and just tighten up on it.
No,
this is a show.
So great.
So at the end I go to his dressing room.
He's in his dressing room in a,
in a silver,
like silk robe.
These little slippers.
Slippers,
slippers.
Oh,
gold stuff on the toes.
And he's got all the makings for Martinis.
Got The ice,
got the olives.
It's got the glass,
the shake,
but just shoves it on his glass.
He just puts it all.
It doesn't even shake.
It just puts ice,
olives and vodka.
You sitting there drinking it and I go to see him.
He's like,
Tom,
come here.
He holds my holds.
My hand doesn't let go of my hand.
It's just the greatest.
He's like,
Tom,
I watched your show tonight.
I watched the whole thing.
Oh,
thank you,
Don.
Thank you.
Have you considered a career in grocery delivery?
You go around and deliver food and you make people happy.
Throw in a joke once in a while to keep yourself in killing yourself
like this is better than the whole vacation.
I'm about to go on with my family so much better.
That.
Did you put pictures?
Did you take pictures of it?
I got a couple shots.
That's huge.
I was just the best.